good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I'm
Philip Wegman on behalf of young
Americans foundation I'd like to welcome
you to this commemoration of Lady
Margaret Thatcher when absolutism
threatened freedom Prime Minister
Thatcher answered liberties call of duty
unwavering in her principles the Iron
Lady championed the cause of freedom
during the darkest hours of the Cold War
as lesser min shrunk away this woman
stood by Reagan side to stare down
communism with her passing we have lost
a courageous leader but gained a rich
legacy of freedom today we are
privileged to hear from our own
president dr. Arnn a friend and close
colleague of this great woman president
Arn and Penny both new lady thatcher and
we are blessed to share in their
memories many of us were born long after
that recept away from politics and sadly
she has begun to recede into the distant
memory of our generation so today I urge
you to honor her legacy learn for her
example and listen well to the words of
dr. Arnn thank you and please join me in
welcoming our president
Thank You mr. Wegman I'm going to begin
by pointing out that I was not Margaret
Thatcher's friends she was a great
person and friendship is 4 equals I was
her admire her and I did happen to know
her pretty well for a long time I get a
chance to thank bill and pat lamothe for
their contribution to the statue right
here they're the best people in the
world and Joe moss who as I think
they're going to get to see this tape
who gave us the chair that mark Nussbaum
over their holes and that Joe is very
proud of mark he was very mindful that
Lady Thatcher had studied chemistry and
if Joe had got his way we would have
named the whole college for Margaret
Thatcher she was born in 1925 in October
her father was a grocer she was born in
Lincolnshire and kind of in the middle
of England as she studied chemistry in
Oxford she got elected to Parliament
pretty soon for finchley which he
represented until she died sorry until
she retired I'm sorry from from the
house of commons she was in the house of
commons from 1959 until her retirement
in 1990 she's one of the great Prime
Minister's in British history one of the
the second longest serving at least in
continuous times I happen to live there
when she was elected when she was when
her party won the nineteen seventy foot
nine election and she became prime
minister the first woman Prime Minister
it was better than watching sports on
television there was nothing like it
every day something big would happen and
every day she would not apologize for it
usually she made it happen I was lucky
enough to know Ron Reagan pretty well
too and my wife and I moved back from
England married couple at that time the
month before ronald reagan was elected
president and he used to say to me
you should move abroad from time to time
and then come back you seem to be lucky
when you do that and that there was
something I told him that he always
remembered i said you know sir you've
always seemed a little soft to me and
the second time he brought that up to me
the same time i ever met him because of
course i'd been watching her and you
just never saw anyone so direct or clear
of speech and she faced a situation that
was devastating it's like the situation
we have today in the country i'll say
something about that in a minute and
what she did was make plain that
situation and place great faith in the
people of her country and then when they
were asked to choose they chose for her
over and over again indeed she never
lost an election after she won the first
one she lost her job as Prime Minister
because her party got tired of her we're
not as strong as she was and they threw
her out that was a big thing and now she
left very nobly i'll tell you a minute
about her connection with the college
she spoke for the college on the campus
here in 1994 she made at least five
other appearances for the college over
the years she was very fond of hillsdale
college she knew all about it when we
would have a cruise that would end in
London we would often put together a
lunch and a dinner and she would come
and I was privileged to have lunch or
dinner with her several times apart from
that when I wrote her about the statue I
was a full of trepidation because she's
an opinionated woman and I was afraid
she'd say no and if she did say no then
it might mean war and certain defeat if
you went ahead anyway but now she was
very friendly to the idea and then Bruce
wolf is the sculptor of this of the
statue he was chosen by a panel of
faculty members I think Tom Connor was
on the faculty committee Sam connect was
for sure and
they recommended him to me and I
wouldn't made a arrangement with him and
I told him I said you know we're going
to have to get the approval of this
woman because I can't imagine having a
statue on him the campus of Hillsdale
College that she didn't like and Bruce
wolf was prepared to he's a very
distinguished copter but he was prepared
to put up with that and so we took to
sending her photographs of the thing as
it was underway and I got a sort of a
mild nice the first time and then my
wife commented on something that I think
was proved to be insightful penny said
maybe the skirts too short so I called a
lady that it worked from Lady Thatcher
that I knew well and Worthing was her
name and I called her up and I said and
I've got a question for you I said is
the skirt too short and Anne said good
point so they weren't telling us but
then after that lady thatcher was
effusive I'll show it to if you want to
see it I got a lovely letter from her
about the statue and how much she
admires it and it is the only statue of
her in North America and after that I
think I mentioned this a complication
but it's worth telling again I saw her
not long after he dedicated the statue
and I showed her photographs of it in
its place she liked him a lot I said
that she'd made a mistake about the
skirt she said why and I said you do
have very nice legs and she said well
I've been told that I'll tell you two
quick stories about her that I observed
there was a cold strike there was a man
named Arthur Scargill who was a very
left-wing I think he was called himself
a communist who was the head of the coal
miners Union and the coal miners were
tough because people got their heat from
coal and so if they didn't mind cold in
the winter then people got cold and
there was a major political party the
other major political party than hers
that was basically controlled in its
governing structure by
the labor unions and the worst or most
aggressive of them was the coal miners
and Margaret Thatcher stored up a bunch
of coal to get ready for a strike
because she knew this guy was going to
do it and he called a strike and he in
the coal mining regions of the country
they had thousands of people picketing
many many companies and parts of the
country basically stopped to function it
happened many times and there was in
nineteen eighty-four I think it was the
Battle of Orgreave it was called there
were five thousand miners and there were
five thousand policemen who showed up to
arrest them and they arrested them all
and there was a hundred and thirty
casualties and I think that was a battle
for the soul of the country and Prime
Minister Thatcher she was then could
remember her going on TV happened to be
there for much of that time in 1984 I
had gone back to do some work and she
was just very clear about it she said
that the stakes in this are enormous and
we're going to stand up for the country
and she had that she's the only
politician I've ever seen who made
powerful rhetorical use of the word
nothing she loved the word nothing and
nothing was always applied in this sense
nothing will make us go back on our
responsibilities and I noticed what the
use of that word did in interviews for
example because journalists love to get
you to say of course I'm mindful of the
other side and then they begin to ask
the series of leading questions about
how you'll move that way if nothing is
your opening position what's the
follow-up question you know if the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse show up
nothing she says and and what happened
was a large part of the membership of
the Mineworkers seceded from the Union
and formed their own Union and made a
deal that was very lucrative
for themselves but not what had been
demanded and she basically broke that
strike and she broke that kind of
unionism the other kind the kind where
people under laws that are fair and and
don't let people take over parts of the
country or the property of others that
kind of thrives in Britain today but you
know there has not been an effort to
bring back that old kind not since she
did that another thing was terrorism you
probably know that lady thatcher was
almost killed they put a bomb in a hotel
they labor the annual Conservative Party
conference is scheduled a year and a
half and there's a certain suite in a
hotel where the head of the party always
stays and so some IRA terrorist checked
into that hotel months in advance and
buried in the wall an explosive device
carefully shielded to go off 11 o'clock
in the morning or midnight in the
bedroom where she slept did go off much
of the hotel and she happened to be her
husband was not with her and she
happened to be working late in the study
next door and her life was spared
although she was seriously injured by
that and that's one of two episodes
because one of her very best friends in
the world was a man named Aaron Eve and
Harry Nev was a very distinguished
soldier in World War two he's one of the
few men to escape German powa up at
coldest and come back and rejoin his
forces and fight out the rest of the war
a very great man by every account very
close to Lady Thatcher and he was the
secretary for Northern Ireland in her
government and they put a bomb in his
car so that when the car was at a
certain high angle such as coming out of
the parking lot underneath the house of
commons the bomb would explode and her
friend airey neave was killed serving in
her government by that bomb having
survived the Nazis so Margaret Thatcher
had strong reasons to oppose terrorism
and so when it happened at about seven
or eight of them as I recall the the key
one was a man named Bobby Sands went
on a hunger strike in the maze prison in
Northern Ireland to be reclassified from
murderers to political prisoners she let
them starve to death and the statements
were remarkable you know because she was
asked about it every night you know it
went on for weeks and she always said
the same thing the thing that I said at
convocation she said when the when the
leader Bobby Sands was reported to her
she was in Saudi Arabia to have died she
said a crime is a crime is a crime
nothing can change that and what that
meant was everybody knew they had chosen
the wrong you know unless they could
string it out until the next election
they had chosen the wrong time to go on
a hunger strike and they didn't back
down and she didn't back down I'll tell
you what I think all that means I've
thought about this most of my adult life
and much of what I think about it is
informed by watching her I think we live
in an age when a new kind of government
has been invented and it's not so much
that it has different aims although it
does have many different aims it has
some of the same aims the point is it
proceeds by a different method today is
Earth Day turns out that Abraham Lincoln
signed the first in the environmental
protection order in American history he
protected Yosemite and if you ever been
there you'll be thankful that he did
that because there's no more beautiful
spot on earth but now we protect the
environment and we do everything else by
a different kind of method and that's
this method is distinguished by rules at
the top rules made by experts who in
their great number gather the force of
government over themselves there's an
agency been created lately in the United
States and that agency does not get its
budget from the Congress of the United
States but from a percentage of the
revenues of the Federal Reserve which
gets its revenues is a government
monopoly bank
that agency has some regulatory power
that may affect us and the Congress of
the United States is forbidden to hold
hearings into the budget of that agency
and it routinely now refuses inquiries
from the Congress about its operations
that means it is sealed off from popular
control and the weight and scale of the
government run by this new method
whatever are the men are the goals that
it pursues means that there's some
chance that the government is going to
overwhelm the society and that is the
very abnegation of liberal politics
liberal in the sense of free a free
people managing those who govern them
because each person born on earth has a
natural right to consent to the
government over him well the greatest
servant of that principle of Liberal
government that I have ever seen with my
own eyes is this lady here and I die I
pray that we will see the like of her
again because the battle over this kind
of government not always the purposes of
government because many of the things
that modern government does including
protecting the environment are very
important they need to be done but there
is a way to do it under constitutions
and under the control of free people for
making that clear for fighting for that
more effectively than I have ever seen
in my own life we today remember this
great woman Baroness Thatcher of
Kesteven thank you for coming
you